Herzlich willkommen zum Tribünengespräch, der ersten Ausgabe unseres neuen Sendeformats beim Rasenfunk. Das Tribünengespräch soll sich nur um ein Thema drehen, das wir mit einem oder mehreren Gästen besprechen und nicht nur den letzten Spieltag beinhalten, sowie die Schlusskonferenz, die ihr alle ja schon kennt hoffentlich. Und alle, die jetzt ihren GoFrank-Pullover anhaben können jubeln, denn beim Tribünengespräch wird auch mein lieber Kollege Frank mehr am Mikrofon zu hören sein. Frank, schön, dass du mit dabei bist. Unser heutiges Thema ist etwas, was vielen Fans schwer auf der Seele liegt, die Winterpause. Kein schönes Thema, wenn man für Fußball sich interessiert und wenn man sich nicht an alten Hallenmasters Wiederholung auf dem D-Straße erfreuen möchte. Für die Fans eine trockene Zeit, für die Spieler eine Erholungszeit und für die Journalisten, ja, das ist die Frage. Und dazu wollen wir uns unterhalten mit einem Journalisten, nämlich mit Daniel Rathjen, Ressortleiter Fußball bei eurosport.com, der unter anderem jetzt gerade mit dem FC Bayern in Doha, in Katar war. Daniel, schön, dass du mit dabei bist. Ja, lass uns direkt bei starten. Mich würde einfach interessieren, wie sieht denn so ein typischer Tag vor Ort aus, wenn du in so einem Trainingslager dabei bist?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich komme jetzt mit frischen Eindrücken von einer Woche Katar, Doha wieder. Die muss man erst mal so ein bisschen auch ordnen und sacken lassen. Der Alltag vor Ort ist ja schon aufwendig, stressig und ja turbulent, kann man auch sagen. Ich vergleiche das immer ganz gern, wenn ich zurückblicke. Ich bin jetzt seit acht Jahren auch regelmäßig beim FC Bayern dabei an der Sebener Straße. Die erste PK, die ich besucht habe, war die Rücktrittspressekonferenz von Sebastian Deißler. Da bin ich hingegangen mit einem Hohelschreiber, einem Notizblock und einem Handy, wo ich dann nach der Pressekonferenz, nachdem ich Sebastian Deißler zugehört habe, eine SMS verschickt habe, um dann in die Redaktion zu fahren und den Artikel zu schreiben. Das hat sich heute ein bisschen gewandelt. Also zu meiner Ausrüstung gehören nicht nur jetzt ein Handy, sondern auch zwei Handys. Ich habe natürlich auch noch einen Notizblock und einen Stift. Ich habe aber auch noch dabei eine Spiegereflexkamera, ein Mikrofon und ein bisschen mehr Erfahrung mittlerweile. Also man merkt schon, dass die Arbeit vielfältiger geworden ist und auch dementsprechend fordernder. Natürlich ist der Druck auch höher geworden. Das liegt vor allem daran, dass die Redaktion in der Regel eigentlich immer kleiner wird. Und auch in anderen Medienhäusern ist natürlich das Geld nicht so locker. Es ist im Vorfeld einfach erstmal schon eine Diskussion. Besetzt man dieses Trainingslager überhaupt, weil es eine Investition ist, eine finanzielle oder halt nicht, entsteht überhaupt ein Mehrwert, wenn ich dir jetzt für eine Woche täglich ausschließlich über den FC Bayern berichte. Und wenn man die erfolgreich bewältigt hat, jetzt aus meinem Sinne und dann hinfahren darf, dann geben einem die Chefs dann gerne mit auf den Weg. Es sollte natürlich auch ein Mehrwert entstehen, etwas, was die anderen nicht haben. Das sollte man doch bitte berichten. Und logischerweise ist das dann mit Klicks verknüpft, wenn man was Exklusives hat, wenn man irgendwie den separaten Blick hat auf diverse Angelegenheiten. Es ist aber natürlich schwer, wenn man mit 20 Kollegen oder mit 25 Kollegen reist, die natürlich auch nur die Zugänge bekommen, die man selbst bekommt, die auch das Gleiche sehen, das Gleiche Training, die gleichen Menschen erleben, die gleichen Gespräche quasi erleben. Ja, aber da liegt so ein bisschen die Herausforderung, ganz generell.
Jetzt wollen wir über den Themendruck, können wir gerne dann noch ein bisschen sprechen. Lass uns noch kurz, damit wir alle dasselbe Bild von deiner Arbeit vor Ort haben, mal so einen typischen Tag durchgehen. Also wahrscheinlich beginnt das mit einem Anrufen der Redaktion oder gehst du direkt gleich zum ersten Training. Wie sieht so ein typischer Tag im Wintertrainingslager für dich aus?
Es geht im Grunde am Vorhaben los, indem ich Themenvorschläge für den nächsten Tag schon aufbereite, in die Redaktion schicke, sodass die gleich die leitenden CVDs, wie auch immer, den Überblick haben, was ich liefern kann, weil dann wirklich zu planen hat man am Morgen dann nicht mehr Zeit. Es ist dann um 8 Uhr, klingelt der Wecker. In Doha ist es ja, man bewegt sich mit dem Taxi fort und die Distanzen sind auch relativ groß. Also von meinem Hotel zum Beispiel bis zum Trainingsende der Bayern-Bars eine Distanz von circa 15 Kilometern. Das kann an guten Tagen 20 Minuten dauern, kann aber auch mal bis zu eine dreiviertel Stunde dauern, je nach Verkehrssituation, die auch durchaus mal chaotisch sein kann. Das heißt, man bewegt sich mit dem Taxi fort, um das einzuordnen. Das ist das billigste tatsächlich. Es gibt weder U-Bahn noch S-Bahn noch irgendwie funktionierendes Bussystem. Es gibt auch, was ganz interessant ist, nicht mal Fußwege, falls man mal irgendwie zu Fuß mal irgendwo hingehen möchte. Es kann sein, dass der Bürgersteig dann einfach mitten auf dem Weg dann aufhört und die achtspurige Straße dann doch irgendwie nicht zu überqueren ist. Jedenfalls fährt man dann mit dem Taxi zum Trainingsgelände, im besten Fall 20 Minuten. Um 10 Uhr war einmal Trainingsbeginn. Man schaut sich das Training an und zu meiner Aufgabe gehört es diesmal auch, neben Artikeln, die ich schreibe für unsere Homepage, Videos zu liefern. Das heißt, ich habe Videomaterial gesammelt, habe mir vorher auch überlegt, welche Videothemen sich anbieten, was ergibt einen Mehrwert für den User. Da habe ich mir den Badstuber zum Beispiel vorgenommen, wie bewegt er sich im Training, aber darauf kann ich später nochmal eingehen. Also die morgendliche Einheit guckt man sich an, filmt schon mal ein bisschen, nimmt Einflüsse auf, hat dann eine halbe Stunde Leerlauf, bis man dann zum Pressegespräch im direkten Mannschaftshotel sitzt. Da kommen dann für gewöhnlich zwei Spieler, die vom Verein bestimmt werden. Und da hat man die Möglichkeit, auch Fragen zu stellen. Natürlich sitzt dann immer ein Pressemitarbeiter des FC Bayern da mit im Raum. Das heißt, es ist nicht ganz ungezwungen. Man kann aber grundsätzlich fragen, was man möchte. Danach gilt es daran, diese Informationen, die man da gesammelt hat, zu verwerten, entweder in einer aktuellen News, wenn sich etwas ergibt, oder in einem Hintergrundbericht, in einer Personalie, die man vielleicht später in der Woche nochmal anwendet. Auch Videoaufsager zu machen, das gehört auch zu meinem Bereich dann dieses Mal. Das kostet auch alles Zeit und Aufwand.
Das machst du komplett alleine oder hast du da noch einen Kameramann mit dabei?
Nein, um das vielleicht nochmal darzulegen, es kommt alles aus einer Hand, was das Trainingslager betrifft. Ich bezeichne mich selber immer so gerne als der erste Mediencyborg, von denen ich vielleicht dann noch in den nächsten Jahren kommen werden. Das heißt, ich bin vor der Kamera, ich habe die Kamera in der Hand, liefe das Bewegtbild, schreibe Texte darüber, befülle parallel Twitter und mache nebenbei noch lustige Handyvideos, die vielleicht bei Facebook gut funktionieren.
Daniel, wenn ich an der Stelle vielleicht kurz einhaken darf, du hast gerade Videoaufsager erwähnt, vielleicht für die weniger medienaffinen Zuhörer. Was ist ein Videoaufsager?
Ja, in meinem Fall stelle ich die Kamera in einer passenden Position auf, dass ich da gut im Bild bin, sprinte dann von hinter der Kamera vor die Kamera mit dem Mikro in der Hand und überlege mir schlaue Sätze, die dann auch Sinn ergeben. Was auch Eindrücke des Trainingslagers beschreiben.
Du hast aber nicht zufällig mit einer zweiten Kamera noch ein Backstage-Video davon gedreht. Das würde mich nämlich tatsächlich interessieren.
Das könnte man vielleicht noch überlegen, so ein Making-of, das wäre dann die weiteren Wege.
Das wäre ein Megametal sozusagen, genau.
Das muss ja immer weitergehen, vielleicht ist das eine Zukunftsidee. Zum Thema Badstuber kann man dann in Worte fassen, was man so gesehen hat. Das passt dann im besten Fall zu den Bildern, die man auch rübersendet. Das Rübersenden ist dann die nächste Herausforderung, weil es wurde uns zwar das beste Internet der Welt versprochen im Medienhotel des FC Bayern. Das trat leider nicht ein, es war eher hakelig. Es ist auch gerne mal ausgefallen, sodass man dann ins Schalke-Mannschaftshotel, was nicht unweit war, rübergegangen ist, was so ein Fußmarsch von ungefähr zehn Minuten war, um da dann zu senden. Da war freizugängliches WLAN und richtig schnell. Das sind immer so die guten Sachen, die dann den Alltag erleichtern. Ja, und das macht man dann am Nachmittag. Man sendet die Sachen rüber, schreibt dann parallel einen Artikel und befüllt Twitter und Facebook, wie erwähnt, bevor dann die zweite Einheit des Tages beginnt. Das ist gegen 17 Uhr. Das heißt, für diese Sachen, die ich gerade beschrieben habe, hat man so ein Zeitfenster von effektiv vielleicht zwei Stunden rüber senden und Artikel schreiben. Nur zu einer Ordnung. Und dann beginnt die zweite Einheit. Da fühlt sich das dann fort, was man am Morgen halt gemacht hat. Wieder Bewegtbildmaterial sammeln, Eindrücke aufnehmen, interpretieren, Auffälligkeiten beobachten und in die diversen Medien verteilen. Genau. Und gegen halb acht ist dann auch die Trainingseinheit beendet. Und ja, zwischendurch war die Zeit wenig vorhanden zum Essen. Dann hat man vielleicht noch mal die Gelegenheit, in die gelegene Mall des Trainingsgeländes zu gehen, da noch ein bisschen zu speisen und ist dann so gegen halb zehn, zehn zurück im Hotel und platt wie sonst was. Und das dann Tag für Tag, acht Tage am Stück. Das ist schon ein Aufwand.
Das heißt, im Grunde eine Art Urlaub für den einfachen Fan.
Es geht ja in die Sonne schließlich, ne?
Das heißt, du musst dich auch noch immer so stellen, dass du in die Sonne gucken musst, damit du keinen Schatten auf deinem Gesicht hast. Ja, jetzt hast du selber vorhin schon angesprochen diesen Themendruck, den es jetzt auch gibt. Jetzt frage ich mich, wenn ich diese ganzen Produktionsbedingungen höre, was macht man denn an einem Tag, an dem einfach dann auch nichts passiert? Also, die trainieren normal, keiner verletzt sich, keiner schnauzt den anderen an. In der Pressekonferenz habe ich einen weniger rhetorisch begabten Spieler, der keine Lust hatte. Das heißt, es gibt auch kein gutes Zitat. Ja, was macht man denn dann?
Ja, das ist dann die große Kunst. Ich verlasse mich da immer so ein bisschen auf mein Auge, auf meine Erfahrung. Und was ich total spannend finde, sind jetzt neben taktischen Themen oder fußballerschen Themen einfach so gruppendynamische Sachen. Wie verhalten sich die Spieler untereinander? Wo gibt es vielleicht irgendwo kleine Details, die man ja so im Alltag nicht erleben kann, weil man sie nicht so lange am Stück sieht, die Spieler? Was kehrt wieder? Welche Formen, Spielformen kehren wieder? Wie verhält sich der einzelne Spieler? Sowas finde ich total spannend. Und wenn mal nichts passiert, dann kann man diese Eindrücke vielleicht dann noch ein bisschen verfestigen und dann auch mal in Worte fassen, in einem Hintergrundbericht. Wie das jetzt zum Beispiel in dieser Woche bei Mitchell Weiser der Fall war.
Mit seinem, ich denke auch mal nach, Zitat.
Ja, also erstmal ist mir das schon aufgefallen, dass er wirklich sich anders verhält als noch vor einem Jahr im Trainingslage. Er ist irgendwie spritziger, ist bissiger und Matthias Sammer spricht dabei immer von dem Wow-Effekt. Den hat er bislang nicht gehabt, aber jetzt in diesem Trainingslage hat er wirklich Aktionen gebracht. Dribblings, Abschlüsse, wo man dachte, oh, das ist Mitchell Weiser. Wow, hätte ich jetzt nicht erwartet. Dazu passend hat er dann nach dem Testspiel gegen die Katar-Auswahl noch relativ offen, was für einen Fußballspieler mittlerweile auch nicht mehr die Regel ist, darüber gesprochen, dass er sich halt mental ein bisschen gewandelt hat. Das war interessant und solche Geschichten kann man dann bringen, wenn mal vielleicht nichts los ist beim Training oder ein langweiliger Spieler, langweilige Aussagen ins Spiel, als auf der Pressekonferenz getätigt wurden.
Ist denn die Option überhaupt mitgedacht, dass du mal an einem Tag sagst, boah Leute, ich müsste mir jetzt nur Sachen aus den Fingern saugen, die dann letztlich keinen wirklichen Gehalt haben, ich schicke euch heute mal kein Artikel und es gibt nur die Aussage oder kann man sich das heutzutage gar nicht mehr leisten, wenn man vor Ort ist?
Das kann man sich definitiv nicht mehr leisten. Mein Pensum an zwei Geschichten, eigentlich pro Tag, morgens, abends plus die genannten Materialien, was Video angeht, Facebook, wir nennen es in der Redaktion immer Crispy-Themen, die ansprechend, knusprig zubereitet werden für den User.
Leicht bekömmlich?
Leicht bekömmliche Kurs sozusagen, genau. Das kann man sich nicht mehr leisten. Dafür ist dann auch der Druck zu groß. Aus der Redaktion und auch von den Kollegen, die ja auch ständig was machen, da will man dann nicht hinten anstehen.
Daniel, jetzt bist du ja dem FC Bayern speziell ziemlich nah. Und da brauchen wir, glaube ich, nicht drüber reden. Der FC Bayern ist wahrscheinlich das, was da klicktechnisch auch die größte Rolle spielt, zumindest unter dem Bundesliga-Verein. Gilt das dann in selber Weise auch für kleinere Vereine oder für, ich will jetzt gar nicht sagen kleinere Vereine, aber für eben die, die nicht ganz oben so in der potenziellen Klickhascheliga stehen? Was weiß ich, gibt es auch für Borussia Mönchengladbach, sind die Journalisten, die die begleiten, dann auch tatsächlich mehr oder weniger dazu gezwungen, da täglich zu liefern? Ist es da ein ähnlicher Druck oder denkst du, dass das für den FC Bayern dann doch ein Extrem ist?
Es war ganz interessant, jetzt wo du das Thema ansprichst, auch Schalke und Bayern im Vergleich zu sehen. Das war wirklich nur die Trennung eines Walts, die da vollzogen wurde. Also links hat der FC Schalke trainiert und rechts der FC Bayern. Beim FC Bayern war eigentlich ständig wirbel. Die Tribünen waren voll, auch beim Training. Arabische Kinder haben, so schnell wie ich es nicht in der Lage bin, irgendwie zu formulieren, Alonso, Alonso, Alonso, Alonso oder Müller, Müller, Müller gerufen. Und bei Schalke war nur ein im Vergleich mickriger Prozentsatz dazu auf der Tribüne. Die haben zwar auch Geheimtrainings gemacht, aber das wäre gar nicht nötig gewesen, weil einfach das Interesse überhaupt nicht so stark war. Die haben ein Testspiel auf ihrem Trainingsplatz durchgeführt. Zuschauer waren da vielleicht auch gerade 100. Und beim FC Bayern mussten sie ihr Testspiel halt in ein riesen Stadion umziehen mit einem Aufwand, der auch beim Champions-League-Spiel hätte betrieben werden müssen. Und da sieht man auch schon so ein bisschen das Interesse, wie das auch in Deutschland gelagert ist. Natürlich ist der Wunsch eines Users immer, man möchte möglichst ausgewogen sein als Redaktion. Nur letztlich haben wir auch die Erfahrung gemacht, die Klick-Tabelle sozusagen ist quasi konform zur wirklichen Tabelle. Der FC Bayern hat da einen extremen Vorsprung. Und da interessiert es tatsächlich dann auch, wie die Ersatzbank sich verhält oder wie sich dann unzufriedene Spieler oder auch Themen am Rande ergeben, die dann einfach bei Bayern an Vereinen gar keine Beachtung finden. Weil die Namen nicht so groß sind. Unser Anspruch ist es, einfach trotzdem ausgewogen zu sein. Wir machen viel Bayern, aber die Berichterstattung soll, was Bayern angeht, auch ausgewogen sein. Weil wir wissen, dass die Leute das interessiert. Es gibt vereinzelte Rufe, dass man mehr über Gladbach machen sollte. Wenn man Berichte über Gladbach macht, interessiert es die Leute nicht, weil man das an den Klickzeilen bemessen kann. Wir sind natürlich im Online-Sektor Klick gesteuert bzw. die Redaktionsleite viel eher. Ich für meinen Teil sehe das eher journalistisch und versuche mich von Klicks ein bisschen unabhängig zu machen. Aber natürlich ist es hier bewusst, dass der FC Bayern an der Spitze steht.
Das heißt aber, es kommt wahrscheinlich deinen Kollegen oder euch insgesamt als Eurosport dann auch zugute, dass viele kleinere Vereine vielleicht an einem Ort – zum Beispiel jetzt in Belek sind ja durchaus einige anzutreffen in der Türkei – an einem Ort sind, weil man einfach journalistisch mit weniger Personal mehr abdecken kann, oder? Weil ihr würdet sicherlich nicht zu jedem Winter-Trainingslager einzeln jemanden schicken.
Richtig, das ist dann eine Kombination, die uns dann ganz gut tut. Also es ist dann im Sommer angenehmer, wenn die – unsere Redaktion sitzt in München für diejenigen, die es nicht wissen, und wenn die Trainingslager im Sommer dann meist in Österreich abgehalten werden. Das sind dann Distanz, die man beim Auto bewältigen kann. Wesentlich einfacher logischerweise.
Jetzt würde mich mal interessieren, schilde uns doch noch mal, welche Möglichkeiten des Zugangs zu den Spielern du hast. Weil das ist ja das Interessanteste eigentlich. Man möchte eigentlich mit den Spielern reden, im Optimalfall in einem Vier-Augen-Gespräch. Ihr habt die Möglichkeit, Pressekonferenzen täglich mit Zitaten, die jeder über Twitter in der Sekunde, in der sie gesagt wurden, schon lesen kann. Welche Möglichkeiten gibt es noch für dich, mit Spielern zu sprechen oder verantwortlich zu sein?
Ja, wie du sagst, das ist einfach natürlich das Ziel, in einem Vier-Augen-Gespräch mit dem Spieler zu kommunizieren, weil dann hat man einen Mehrwert, dann hat man etwas, was die anderen nicht haben. Nur man geht auch davon aus, dass die Spieler sich mitteilen möchten. Das ist so ein bisschen in Irrglaube geworden mittlerweile, wo ja auch der Wandel der Medienarbeit sich zeigt. In den letzten Jahren hat der FC Bayern sehr stark seine eigene Medienarbeit forciert – bei FCB.de, bei FCB.tv. Marketingmäßig soll auch das amerikanische und das asiatische Gebiet erobert werden. In diesem Zusammenhang hat sich das auch für die Spieler verändert. Jetzt während des Trainingslagers werden die auch von den Vereinseigen den Medien angesprochen für einzelne – ich kann jetzt den Fachbegriff verwenden, weil es die Leute wissen – Aufsager verwendet für ein paar Sätze auf Chinesisch, ein paar Sätze auf Englisch, ein paar Sätze auf ich weiß nicht was. Dann wird wiederum ein Video gedreht, wie sie der Handball-Nationalmannschaft viel Glück wünschen. Und Manuel Neuer und ich weiß nicht, welche Spiele noch dabei waren, Thomas Müller mit Sicherheit, da irgendwelche witzigen Aktionen machen. Das sind alles Themen, die man als Redaktion sich auch hätte vornehmen können, wenn man den Zugang gehabt hätte. Nur da greift heute der FC Bayern auch als Erstverwerter zu und wir sind quasi abhängig auch von den Spielern, die uns dann zur Verfügung gestellt werden in der Presserunde. Das sind natürlich immer attraktive Namen, nur man muss auch sagen, die Leute oder die Spieler, die sich wirklich intellektuell mit ihrer Materie auseinandersetzen oder sich das auch dann vor Augen führen, was wichtig ist und was vielleicht analytisch ist, die kann man mittlerweile an einer Hand abzählen und die das auch natürlich mitteilen möchten. Das sind im aktuellen Fall aus meiner Sicht Arjen Robben, Thomas Müller, Manuel Neuer, Philipp Lahm und Holger Bartschuber, mit denen man wirklich sprechen kann, die Interesse daran haben, irgendwie auch mit der Presse zu sprechen. Die anderen, so scheint es mir, sind so ein bisschen übersättigt, wittern von uns irgendwie oder wittern bei uns nur verstärkt, dass wir irgendwas Negatives konzipieren wollen, dass wir ihnen etwas Böses möchten und ja, flüchten sich dann in so Floskeln, die immer nichts sagen werden einfach. Ich habe zum Beispiel den David Alaba unter der Woche mal fragen wollen, ob er jetzt das als nächsten Schritt begreift, dass er nicht mehr linksverteidiger war ausschließlich in der Hinrunde, sondern mehr ins Zentrum gerückt ist, mehr da ist, wo das Geschehen sich abspielt im Offensivbereich. Dessen Antwort war dann, ja ich spiele da, wo der Trainer mich hinstellt. Das hatte ich mir auch anders vorgestellt ehrlich gesagt. Da ist es dann ein bisschen frustrierend manchmal, weil man einfach merkt, man kann kein Vertrauensverhältnis mehr zu den Spielern aufbauen. Man kommt einfach nicht mehr nah genug ran. Im Trainingslag jetzt in Doha war es der Fall, dass man zumindest noch mal nach dem Training die Möglichkeit hatte, wenn die Spieler vom Rasen in die Kabine gegangen sind, eilenden Schritte mit ihnen in die Richtung Kabine zu gehen und vielleicht da ein, zwei Fragen nochmal loszuwerden. Das war es dann aber auch schon. Man erhofft sich immer mehr, als man dann tatsächlich bekommt von so exklusiven Gesprächen. Wichtig für mich und so ist meine Herangehensweise auch der exklusive Blick, das Privileg anzuwenden, die Erfahrung zu haben und die Trainingsanhalte zu beobachten. Das ist das, worauf es für mich ankommt mittlerweile mehr und mehr.
Am Anfang sagt, dass das natürlich auch für deinen Chef und für die Redaktion entscheidend ist und die einfach Dinge hören und sehen wollen, die möglichst dann nur ihr habt. Gibt es denn da überhaupt noch viele Möglichkeiten, außer du stehst natürlich mit deiner Erfahrung und mit deiner journalistischen Kompetenz draußen und kannst vielleicht eine gute Geschichte machen aus Dingen, die du dir zusammen kombinierst, aus Informationen, die du bekommst, aber tatsächlich Informationen exklusiver Art? Ich meine, wenn ich das jetzt so höre, an die Spieler kommt man eigentlich nicht ran. Und selbst wenn, dann sagen sie teilweise gar nichts, wollen nichts sagen. Das wird bei den Verantwortlichen nicht so viel anders sein, oder? Gibt es da irgendwie bei Matthias Sammer, der ist ja noch viel mehr Medienprofi und steuert das, was er nach draußen gibt, ganz genau? Gibt es sonst irgendwo Möglichkeiten, einfach irgendwie an Informationen zu kommen, die jetzt vielleicht ein anderer nett hat? Ja, es gibt doch insgesamt dünn, oder?
Das ist dünn und es geht nur über dieses angesprochene Vertrauensverhältnis, was ich kann jetzt sagen im Vergleich früher halt einfacher war, das aufzubauen, weil die Spieler noch nicht so übersättigt waren, was die Medienarbeit angeht. Das heißt, Mark von Bommel zum Beispiel, früher, mit dem konnte man wirklich auch dann mal ein Hintergrundgespräch führen. Den hat man angesprochen und gesagt, um einen Artikel zu schreiben, brauche ich eine fundierte Sichtweise, eine fundierte Meinung. Und es wäre schön, wenn wir mal fünf Minuten einfach jetzt auf the Records über gewisse Dinge halt sprechen konnten. Das konnte man noch machen, aber dadurch, dass man halt jetzt immer mehr, ich nenne es mal, drastisch abgeschnitten wird von den Zugängen, ist es immer schwieriger, diese Basis aufzubauen, auf der nur so was möglich ist. Es funktioniert ganz oft so auch im Journalismus, dass man mit Leuten spricht, Hintergrundgespräche führt und die dann sagen, das erzähle ich dir jetzt so, aber schreibst bitte nicht so. Das ist einfach für deinen für deinen Hinterkopf, damit du gewisse Dinge verstehen kannst. Und zu diesem Austausch kommt es irgendwie nicht mehr. Da sind nur noch wenige Redaktionen wirklich in der Lage, das auch zu schaffen und das auch unter sehr strenger Beobachtung des FC Bayern.
Jetzt hast du gesagt, dass vor allem daran liegt dieses gestörte Verhältnis zu den Spielern. Ich kenne es jetzt einfach mal gestört. An der Übersättigung der Spieler hängt es vielleicht auch ein bisschen damit zusammen, dass die Sportberichterstattung zumindest in meinem Empfinden nach in den letzten Jahren immer Boulevardeska geworden ist.
Ja, es ist auch eine Entwicklung, die da mit Sicherheit hereinspielt. Das wollte ich vorhin sagen, dass die Spieler immer wittern, wir wollen ihnen etwas Böses. Vielleicht sind das die Lehren, die sie für sich daraus ziehen, aus diesen Boulevardesken ansetzen. Es ist sicherlich auch irgendwie ein Lernprozess der Medien, die am Anfang gemerkt haben, Boulevardeske oder drastische Schlagzeilen klicken einfach besser oder verkaufen sich besser. Da muss man sich natürlich auch irgendwie selbst hinterfragen. Vielleicht ist jetzt gerade auch die Schwelle aktuell vorhanden, dass man wieder ein bisschen mehr zur Sachlichkeit zurückkehrt. Das kann durchaus sein und dass es dann darauf basierend wieder auch mehr Qualität unter den Journalisten gibt, die für sich vielleicht dann auch taktische Begriffe irgendwie fehlerfrei verwenden können oder dann nicht mehr so bunte Themen interessant sind, sondern das es wirklich tatsächlich nur noch sich aufs Sportliche beschränkt. Ich glaube, das kommt den Spielern dann auch entgegen und über das Sportliche sprechen sie generell eigentlich schon gern.
Jetzt hast du gerade schon die anderen Journalisten angesprochen, das finde ich ist eine ganz spannende Frage, weil du hast ja jetzt schon beschrieben, dass es sehr schwierig ist wirklich exklusive Zitate oder exklusive Hintergrundinformation zu bekommen. Das heißt, mehr oder weniger arbeiten alle Journalisten vor Ort mit demselben Material und müssen daraus was stricken. Wie ist denn das Verhältnis der Journalisten untereinander? Liest man da die Texte des anderen und spricht nochmal darauf an, welchen Dreh derjenige gefunden hat? Ist es kooperativ oder konfrontativ?
Ja, das ist eher kooperativ. Man bildet ja auch so ein bisschen eine Gemeinschaft, weil man dann auch in gewisser Weise in einem Boot sitzt. Natürlich ist jeder irgendwie dann sich selbst der Nächste, wenn es um eine exklusive Geschichte geht. Aber prinzipiell ist da ein bisschen Solidargemeinschaft, weil letztlich alle von den Launen der Presseabteilung oder der Spieler halt abhängig sind. Von daher kann ich mich jetzt unter der Woche in Doha erinnern, da habe ich zum Beispiel den Bastian Schweinsteiger gefragt, weil es wirklich augenscheinlich war und ganz offensichtlich, woher eigentlich seine krasse Wadenmuskulatur kommt, ob er da eigentlich mehr macht. Das ist ein Hingucker, da standen wir im Pulk zusammen, die Journalisten, und haben uns einfach über diese Waden unterhalten, die, wenn man sie wirklich live sieht, total ins Auge stechen. Da habe ich ihn drauf angesprochen, und dann sagte der Kollege von der Süddeutschen Zeitung, ja, das war irgendwie eine interessante Frage, ich hatte mir schon meinen Einstieg zurechtgelegt, jetzt kommt das Zitat natürlich dazu, und ja, soll ich es dir jetzt überlassen? Ich mache das trotzdem, ja, und es ist aber auch nicht schlimm, weil der Markt einfach groß genug ist. Ob das jetzt in der Süddeutschen Zeitung steht und bei Eurosport, das ist dann zweitrangig, weil ich habe dann die Geschichte ein bisschen anders aufgezogen. Die Süddeutsche hat den lang formulierten, ganz fein formulierten Einstieg gewählt, ich habe es dann fürs Internet ein bisschen brachialer gemacht, habe ein Foto von den Waden gemacht, Fotos mache ich auch noch nebenbei, und habe dann einfach getitelt, das Geheimnis hinter diesen Waden. Er hat dann letztlich gesagt, ich komme vom Skifahren, er macht gar nichts extra dafür. Und ja, mein Ansatz war es aber, einerseits irgendwie einen Klickreiz oder ein bisschen amüsanten Klickreiz zu schaffen und diesen Text dann, der von der Aussage, ich komme vom Skifahren, eigentlich belanglos ist, aber dann ein bisschen mit Substanz zu füllen und zu sagen, mit diesen Waden hat er halt noch viel vor. Mehr ist jetzt wieder im besten Begriff da, irgendwie der Alte zu werden und ja, so stellt er sich den Rest der Saison vor. Also, um darauf zurückzukommen, es ist schon teilweise kooperativ, wenn man in einem Boot sitzt. Nichtsdestotrotz gibt es natürlich immer auch wieder Konfrontationen und ja, Kampf um die besten Zitate. Aber das ist ganz normal.
Jetzt ist es ja so, dass die wichtigsten Zitate, die kann ich als Fan zum Beispiel ganz einfach über die sozialen Kanäle auch selbst schon mitbekommen, ja letztlich auch durch die Berichterstattung des FC Bayern selbst. Ist denn dann jetzt der Grund, dass du dich in der Diskussion gegen deine Chefs durchsetzen kannst und sagst, ich fliege damit runter, sind das dann einfach die acht Jahre Erfahrung und dass du eben einen Text über die Waden von Skifahrer Schweinsteiger noch anführen kannst mit weiteren Informationen, die darüber hinausgehen?
Ja, das ist sicherlich so ein Zusammenspiel. Man muss halt vielseitig sein. Dieses Drehmediale, das kann jetzt auch nicht jeder, ein klassischer Radioreporter, der sein Leben lang nichts anderes gemacht hat, kann jetzt nicht auf einmal, ohne jetzt da irgendjemand diskreditieren zu wollen, vor der Kamera auch agieren oder mit der Kamera und gleichzeitig Texte schreiben. Das ist sicherlich dann auch ein Stück weit irgendwie gelernte Qualität. Andererseits zeichnet einen guten Journalisten auch immer der Blick und der Fokus auf das Interessante, auf das Wesentliche aus. Ich führ da mal ganz gerne ein Beispiel an, das war auch jetzt in dieser Saison das Spiel in Manchester. 45.000 Leute im Stadion, ich war auch live vor Ort auf der Tribüne, zigtausend Kameras, ich weiß es nicht, Handykameras und fernab des Geschehens leistet sich Franck Ribéry mit Vincent Compagnie eine handfeste Schlägerei, formuliere ich das jetzt mal überspitzt. Also der Compagnie rennt auf den Ribéry zu, schubst ihn, der Ribéry schlägt zurück mit einer Ohrfeige. Das hat keine Kamera aufgenommen, es hat ja keiner der 45.000 Zuschauer irgendwie thematisiert, aber ich habe es in dem Moment gesehen und diesen Vorfall halt genau beschrieben. Das war dann natürlich eine relativ erfolgreiche Meldung, weil es ein exklusiver Blick war. Und da zeichnet sich dann schon auch ein Mehrwert aus, dass es dann letztlich auch schon was ausmacht, ob man einen Mitarbeiter vor Ort hat oder halt nicht.
Würdest du denn sagen, die Arbeitsbedingungen, die du beschrieben hast, das reicht, um auch wirklich guten, inhaltstiefen Journalismus zu produzieren, weil das hört sich relativ taff an, wenn man zwei Stunden Zeit hat, um ein Video hochzuladen, wahrscheinlich noch irgendwie zumindest rough ein bisschen zu schneiden und dann noch einen Text zu schreiben? Oder würdest du sagen, das ist halt heutzutage einfach so, man muss einfach sehr schnell guten Content produzieren können?
Ja, also es gibt natürlich kompakte Tage, wo man wirklich dann sich vielleicht auf News fokussieren muss, die dann nicht so tiefgründig sind und muss sich dann die Zeit so einteilen, dass man über komplexere Themen dann mal in Ruhe nachdenkt und vielleicht dann sich eine Phase raussucht nach dem Trainingslager, wo man dann vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Zeit hat zu schreiben. Aber ich gebe dir recht mit der Vermutung, dass die Zeit für tiefgründige Recherche und ganz komplexe Gedanken, so wie es vielleicht ein Fan oder auch Blogger haben, die sich bei Sky eine komplette Übertragung anschauen, mit Vorberichterstattung, dann im Spiel mit zig Zeitlupen, sämtliche Zitate scannen, dann Nachberichterstattung, die Meinung von Experten noch auswerten können. Das kann so ein Reporter vor Ort einfach nicht. Da ist er dann alleine auf sich gestellt, im Grunde auch in der Zeit, die ihm zur Verfügung steht. Und ja, das ist dann schon auch eine Herausforderung und sicherlich auch eine Entwicklung, die sich in den letzten Jahren so ergeben hat.
Jetzt warst du ja nicht nur einfach im Wintertrainingslager des FC Bayerns, sondern du warst im Hashtag VolkswagenCampKatar. Wie hat sich denn die Rolle der Sponsoren vor Ort verändert?
Ja, es ist schon sehr dominant, also nicht nur im Hashtag, sondern vor Ort hat sich Volkswagen natürlich auch als der Partner da irgendwie positioniert. Man darf es ja auch nicht vergessen, der FC Bayern bekommt ja eine gewisse Summe, dass sie überhaupt ihr Trainingslager in Doha, in Katar abhalten. Volkswagen wiederum bekommt dann durch Hashtags oder wie auch immer die Aufmerksamkeit, die sie halt haben wollen bei jedem Trainingsbild, deren Schriftzug zu lesen und die waren da schon sehr präsent, muss man sagen. Aber das ist keine große Überraschung gewesen. Die spielen mittlerweile natürlich eine sehr starke Rolle, die Sponsoren. Und das ist womöglich auch der einzige Grund neben den optimalen Bedingungen mal, dass die Bayern überhaupt nach Doha gefahren sind letztlich.
Die Kosten, die ihr allerdings als Journalisten habt, die tragen nämlich mal an eure Arbeitgeber bzw. Verlage wie auch immer komplett. Das heißt, das Sponsoring reicht da nicht in den journalistischen Bereich, oder?
Ich habe keinen Privatsponsor, nee.
Ihr macht euch ja ein Stück weit zu Werkzeugen, oder? Ihr seid ja diejenigen, die die Bilder übermitteln, auf denen dann VW im Hintergrund ist, oder?
Werbebanden sind jetzt nichts Neues irgendwie.
Stimmt natürlich, ja.
Und auch der Sponsor auf dem Trikot wird abgebildet, klar. Das ist immer die Grenze, dann zu ziehen. Ich kaufe mir jetzt keinen Volkswagen extra, deswegen, weil sie jetzt den FC Bayern dieses Trainingslager ermöglicht haben.
Pass auf, dass du deinen Job jetzt nicht verlierst, wenn du sowas machst.
Ich glaube, das hängt davon hoffentlich nicht ab. Der Arbeitgeber zahlt diese Reise für mich, und da sind wir dann frei von Sponsoren. Vielleicht ist es auch ein Anreiz, dass man sich noch ein bisschen Unabhängigkeit bewahrt. Vielleicht, wenn man da auch noch in irgendwelche Pflichten gedrückt werden muss. Das muss ja nicht sein.
Thema Unabhängigkeit, da komme ich dann direkt auf das Thema Katar selbst zu sprechen. Du hast es selbst schon angesprochen. Katar positioniert sich irgendwie als Sportweltmacht aus dem Nichts. Wie kritisch kann man darüber berichten? Gibt es eigentlich noch die Möglichkeit, auch vor Ort vielleicht dazu recherchieren, auch für andere Artikel? Wie siehst du das ganze Thema Katar?
Ja, es ist natürlich zwiespaltig. Ich kann jetzt nur meine Eindrücke wiedergeben und das Land ist einfach turbulent. Es ist wild. Es ist, wenn ich an Katar denke, eine einzige Baustelle. Wenn ich jetzt so die Taxifahrt zum Trainingsgelände Revue passieren lasse, sehe ich Baustelle, Baustelle, Baustelle, riesig Tag und Nacht, sind da Arbeiter am Werk. Dann sehe ich die Wohngebiete, sogenannte Compounds, die von Wohnanlagen, die von riesigen Mauern halt umgeben sind, wo sich innen wahrscheinlich Leben abspielt, aber man es von außen überhaupt nicht sieht. Das heißt, nach Baustellen, Baustellen, Baustellen kommen dann Compounds, Compounds, Compounds. Solche des Trainingsgeländes FC Bayern oder auch Malls, die es da als touristische Ausflugsziele gibt, sind dann fast Inseln, wo die Welt schon ein bisschen unwirklich ist. Auch das Aspire-Gelände, wo dann der FC Bayern gastiert hat und Schalke, ist halt so eine Insel für sich. Die Bedingungen, die sind wirklich exorbitant gut. Der Rasen hat dieses Kunstrasen-Echtrasen-Gemisch. Das ist kein Teppich, das ist das Parkett unter den Fußballplätzen. Das ist Wahnsinn. Natürlich sind da auch ständig Arbeiter vor Ort. Man sieht da wenig Müll oder so rumliegen. Es ist irgendwie ein bisschen unwirklich, wenn man das Drumherum sieht, dass es dann auch so leicht staubig wirkt. Als staubig im Sinne von Sandfarben. Da ist dann so eine grüne Inde, so eine Oase der Sportlichkeit. Auch so sind die Stadien konzipiert. Der Weg zu den Stadien kann schon mal auch da nervig sein aufgrund des Verkehrs. Im Stadion selbst ist alles hochmodern und Geld ist da ohne Ende offenbar vorhanden. Das spürt man an jeder Ecke, wenn man dann in so einer Insel sich befindet. Ob es jetzt dann immer gerecht verteilt wird, wage ich mal auch stark zu bezweifeln. Wenn man sich die Bevölkerung auch mal dezidiert anschaut, das Land – ich weiß es jetzt nicht ganz konkret – hat, glaube ich, knapp über eine Million Einwohner. Grundfläche wie Baden-Württemberg so ca. ich weiß es nicht genau – zehn Prozent der Einwohner sind aber nur echte Katari. Der Rest sind halt auch Gastarbeiter. Und ja, das birgt schon einen Konflikt in sich irgendwie.
Und habt ihr da, als es darum ging, die Reise zu organisieren, braucht man dann Visum, um nach Katar zu kommen?
Nein, braucht man nicht. Das ist für Deutsche reicht ja normal Reisepass.
Gab es da irgendwelche Hinweise, worüber er besser nicht berichten sollte? Oder gab es irgendwelche Einschränkungen oder irgendwas in dieser Art?
Für Kamerateams ist eine Drehgenehmigung quasi notwendig. Da muss man halt beim Staat direkt anmelden, beim Staat oder beim Emirat Katar, dass man da Aufnahmen tätigen will. Das kann dazu führen, dass man dann von vornherein unter Beobachtung steht und da auch sicherlich darauf geschaut wird, was man da filmt.
Gilt es auch für einen Mann Kamerateams dann?
Ich habe jetzt keine Probleme gehabt. Ich fürchte jetzt keine im Nachhinein. Aufgrund der eher kompakten Zeit, die ich zur Verfügung hatte, oder des straffen Zeitplans, habe ich jetzt auch wenig um diese Inseln herum erforschen können. Das ist einfach nur, was man am Rande mitbekommt.
Das ist natürlich genau das, was Katar möchte. Du warst an den Stellen, die auch Katar möchte, dass gesehen werden. Die wesentlich größeren Felder, die man nicht sieht, sollen auch nicht gesehen werden. Wie kritisch habt ihr denn selber darüber diskutiert, intern in der Redaktion und vielleicht auch das in die Berichterstattung einfließen lassen? War das ein Thema?
Es war im Grunde wenig ein Thema. Eurosport liegt im Namen. Wir stellen den Sport nach vorne und weniger das politische. Natürlich ist es ein Thema, über das man auch diskutiert, inwieweit das in unser Profil passt. Ob die Jose von uns einen kritischen Bericht zur politischen Lage in Katar erwarten oder vielleicht eher von großen Zeitungen wie der FAZ, Welt, Süddeutschen. Dann schon eher vielleicht.
Aber nehmt ihr euch da nicht ein bisschen leicht aus der Verantwortung? Ihr werdet doch wahrscheinlich auch über die WM-Vergabe nach Katar relativ kritisch berichtet haben, oder?
Ja, es ist eine zwiespältige Sache irgendwo. Ich kann jetzt auch nur voller Überzeugung sagen, dass ich da ganz objektiv auch berichte und das berichte, was ich gesehen habe. Ich lasse mir da nichts aufbürden oder habe da irgendwelche Skrupel, was zu schreiben. Nur wie gesagt, ich sehe immer das gerne, bevor ich etwas berichte. Ich habe jetzt vor Ort in dieser Woche wenig Gelegenheit gehabt, auch diese Orte zu besuchen, außerhalb dieser Inseln. Deswegen kann ich mir zwar ein Urteil bilden, aber ob ich das jetzt für die breite Masse zugänglich machen möchte, ist wieder eine andere Sache. Das muss man dann vielleicht in einer Themenwoche oder in der Zeit zum Recherchieren oder mit den entsprechenden Leuten zu sprechen thematisieren. Es war vor Ort auch ein bisschen schwierig. Es gab durchaus auch Ansätze von Kritik in den Fragen. Zum Beispiel ob es tatsächlich Sinn macht, eine WM in Katar bei 55 Grad im Sommer in der Sonne zu bestreiten. Nur die Zitate, die man auch von Pep Guardiola oder von einem Scheich, der neben ihm saß, dessen Namen mir jetzt nicht mehr einfällt, bekommt, die sind auch vorhersehbar. Die sitzen natürlich – es ist natürlich auch für die eine schwierige Situation – die können nicht so kritisch wie sie vielleicht damit umgehen wollen, mit dem Thema des nach außen Posaunen, weil sie ja irgendwo dann auch profitieren von den Finanzen, die sie dazu geschossen bekommen. Ich glaube, der Arjen Robben hat das ganz gut auf den Punkt gebracht. Irgendwo habe ich jetzt ein Zitat gelesen, dass er gesagt hat, er hat eine Meinung, aber die möchte er nicht kundtun. Ich habe vorhin schon gesagt, ich achte ein bisschen auf die Zwischentöne, auf die Blicke, auf die ganzen sensiblen Geschichten. Immer wenn das Katar-Thema auf den Tisch kam und es leicht kritisch wurde, hat man den Pressesprecher auch ein bisschen nervös hin und her rutschen sehen. Also das ist ein sensibles Thema. Sie können nicht so darüber sprechen, wie sie vielleicht wollten, weil sie natürlich da auch profitieren.
Das ist ganz klar. Jetzt hast du erklärt, dass ihr das trennt und warum ihr das trennt. Jetzt hast du aber mit Pep Guardiola zum Beispiel einen angesprochen, der das ja gar nicht trennt. Also der ist ja ganz privat auch in Vermarktungsdiensten für Katar unterwegs und deshalb wird man von ihm natürlich auch nichts Kritisches hören. Wäre es dann nicht die Aufgabe, sowas zumindest zu thematisieren? Also auch das vielleicht einfach auch nur darzulegen, weil das ja auch nicht jeder Fan weiß.
Das wäre ein Thema, ja durchaus habe ich auch drüber nachgedacht und ja, wird man vielleicht nächste Woche lesen.
Ich hätte dann gerne eine kleine Überweisung für diesen Themenvorschlag. Also vielleicht abschließend zu dem Thema Katar. War das jemals Thema vielleicht zu sagen, aus diesem Grund nicht mit ins Trainingslager zu fliegen? Bei Berichten kann man auch von Deutschland aus, wenn halt dann mit abzüglich dessen, was du quasi durch deine Erfahrung vor Ort als Mehrwert bieten kannst. War das ein Thema, an dem Punkt quasi eine weiche Entscheidung, sage ich jetzt mal, zu treffen? Also ihr verzichtet nicht komplett auf die Berichterstattung. Das könnt ihr euch nicht erlauben, aber ihr setzt ein Zeichen, in dem ihr nicht mitfliegt. Wurde das mal thematisiert?
Ich denke, das wurde nicht thematisiert. Es wäre aber auch jetzt kein Zeichen, glaube ich, was für Aufsehen sorgen würde, wenn Eurosport jetzt nicht mit vor Ort wäre. Man könnte sich natürlich so positionieren, ob das jetzt ein wirkliches Zeichen für andere wäre, weiß ich nicht. Dafür ist dann das auch noch nicht bewusst erörtert worden alles. Sicherlich schwierig das Ganze.
Jetzt bist du jetzt schon so lange dabei, und das war jetzt wahrscheinlich dann auch, wenn du sagst, seit acht Jahren, dann warst du im Minimum dein achtes Trainingslager, eher wahrscheinlich dein sechzehntes, bei dem du mit den Bayern warst. Wie war denn das vor acht Jahren? Bist du da tatsächlich nur mit dem Notizblock runtergefahren? Also einen Laptop wirst du schon gehabt haben?
Einen Laptop hatte ich, ja, und Internet gab es auch schon, aber man hatte halt noch ein bisschen mehr Leerlauf zwischendurch, als es Twitter noch nicht gab, als es Facebook noch nicht so präsent war, irgendwie als auch neuer Verbreitungskanal. Die Arbeit an sich hat sich nicht geändert, nur die Mittel, die man dafür einsetzt. Letztlich hat man sich die gleichen Gedanken gemacht, weil es bleibt ja irgendwo auch Fußball, und es bleiben die gleichen Themen, um die es sich dreht. Tore sind wichtig und wie man sie zustande bringt auch. Von daher hat sich da nicht so viel gewandelt, außer die Mittel, die man einsetzt. Aber die Themen und die Gedanken, die man sich gemacht hat, die sind gleich geblieben.
Du bist selber auf Twitter auch aktiv als Daniel Rathjen. Siehst du die sozialen Netzwerke als Mehrwert oder eher als Hindernis für deine Arbeit, weil die wichtigsten Begebenheiten sich sowieso so schnell verbreiten, dass es dann eher darum geht, News schnell zu verbreiten, als irgendwie einen Hintergrundbericht zu machen?
Ja, es rundet irgendwie die Berichterstattung ab, finde ich. Klar, man bekommt die wichtigsten Zitate auch schnell. Und das ist gut. Ich nutze das natürlich auch als erste Informationsquelle, weil man wirklich einen kompakten Überblick bekommt über die wichtigsten Sachen. Und es ist einfach zu dem Medium geworden, wo man die erste News platzieren kann. Und das ist halt auch eine Entwicklung. Und man muss dann im gleichen Schritt überlegen, wie verwertet man die News jetzt in weitere Interpretationen. Was bedeutet das jetzt? Es reicht halt nicht mehr, wie früher, dass man eine Nachricht abbildet, sondern am besten muss man mit dem Spielbericht schon eine Richtung einschlagen. Und das schärft irgendwie auch die Sinne so ein bisschen. Das wird halt alles ein bisschen schneller, aber es rundet irgendwie das ganze Profil ab, weil man dann Sachen einfach dann auch über Twitter verbreiten kann, die vielleicht im Artikel irgendwie jetzt untergehen würden. Und von daher lässt sich das alles gut kombinieren.
Du bist jetzt seit acht Jahren dabei, Daniel. Max hat vorhin schon gesagt, wahrscheinlich 16 Trainingslager, also auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge. Dass in den 16 Jahren bestimmt irgendwie Dinge passiert, die einem so im Sinn bleiben über die Jahre hinweg. Gibt es da irgendwas, wo du sagst, Mensch, da ist das eine hier oder da, da sind schon tolle Sachen passiert oder fällt dir da irgendwas ein?
Spontan ist natürlich irgendwie schwierig, da jetzt das Entscheidende irgendwie rauszufiltern. Ich finde generell ganz interessant, mit den Trainern irgendwie zusammenzuarbeiten, weil die ja doch sehr spezielle Typen auch waren. Ob das jetzt ganz am Anfang Felix Magath war oder ein Jürgen Klinsmann zwischendurch, ein Louis van Raal. Ja, das waren für mich immer schon die eigentlichen Protagonisten. Das sind auch diejenigen, mit denen man dann auch am regelmäßigsten unter der Woche spricht, weil sie dann auch am meisten zu sagen haben.
Auch nur im Rahmen der Pressegespräche? Oder gibt es da tatsächlich mal ein Gespräch am Spielfeldrand?
Ja, mit Pep Guardula jetzt weniger. Mit den anderen Trainern war das durchaus mal möglich. Ich erinnere mich da an 2009 war das in Donau-Eschingen die erste Saison von Louis van Raal. Da war für uns Journalisten auch noch nicht so richtig greifbar. Was ist das eigentlich für ein Typ? Wirkt er irgendwie ganz interessant, dennoch irgendwie so unnahbar? Er hat dann auch eine Pressekonferenz geben und seine Philosophie so ein bisschen dargelegt. Dann folgte die Trainingsreinheit. Er hat, ich glaube, die Viererkette, Schwerpunkt Meeseck, behandelt in dem Training. Ich habe ihn danach nochmal angesprochen und wollte ihm eine Frage stellen zu einer – ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr – zu einem Detail. Dann hat er ganz harsh geantwortet und mich in seiner bekannten Art und Weise irgendwie so heruntergemacht. Sie waren doch auch bei der Pressekonferenz. Dann habe ich gesagt, ja, dann haben sie doch alles gehört. Ja, habe ich auch. Aber ich sage, gerade beim Training ist mir noch was aufgefallen. Da würde ich noch mal gerne drauf eingehen. Ja, dann fragen sie. Also, man muss ihnen immer so ein bisschen Kontra geben oder einen Grund liefern. Dann hat er auch ganz nett und ganz ausführlich geantwortet. Und das fand ich an Louis van Gaal irgendwie ehrlich und gut. Das ist jetzt so eine kleine Anekdote, natürlich tausend andere, aber ja.
Aber es gibt quasi keine Spieler, die irgendwie nachts über die Mauer des Aspire klettern und irgendwie noch einheben gehen. So was kriegt man heutzutage nicht mehr oder kriegen wir es einfach nur alle nicht mit?
Dazu gehört ja, dass sich die Spieler untereinander gut verstehen. Ich glaube auch, dass die immer mehr auf sich fixiert sind, auch die Spieler. Dieses Motto 11 Freunde müsste sein, das ist natürlich schon längst überholt.
Die jungen Spieler sind da geworden.
Ja, richtig. Und die Spieler an sich, gerade die Jungen, sind auch extrem diszipliniert. Die sind durch diese Internate teilweise oder schwerpunktmäßig auch gegangen. Die wissen, dass sie sich das einfach nicht erlauben können, aus diversen Gründen. Das findet dann vielleicht eher so im Verborgenen statt. Nach der Champions-Seek-Feier in Wembley im Mannschaftshotel, hatten sie einen Raum zu ihrer Disco umfunktioniert. Die sind dann noch nicht mal irgendwo öffentlich in ein Club gegangen, sondern sie haben sich kurz nach dem Mannschaftshotel einfach eine Disco einrichten lassen und sind da schon sehr, sehr vorsichtig geworden. Also die Geschichten, die interessant sie manchmal irgendwie sein mögen, die kriegt man dann doch nicht mit, wahrscheinlich.
Und wie ist es bei den Journalisten? Haut ihr abends dann so richtig auf den Putz, wenn ihr alle eure Absichtspunkte als Kameraproducer, Aufnehmer, Regisseur, Mikrofonmann und Texteschreiber absolviert habt?
Ja, also in Doha gibt es ja grundsätzlich keinen Alkohol, deswegen, ja, der ein oder andere Kollege taut dann deshalb gar nicht erst auf. Nein, aber wir gehen schon noch mal essen und ja, lassen so ein bisschen auch Themen noch mal kreisen, gedanklich vielleicht, oder sprechen darüber und ja, ein paar alte Hasen sind natürlich auch dabei, dann werden Legenden ausgepackt und das ist dann immer ganz unterhaltsam.
Das hat sich jetzt alles sehr kompakt und anstrengend angehört, wenn ich das so revue-palieren lasse. Du machst das jetzt schon im achten Jahr. Wie viele Trainingslage wirst du dir noch geben? Spürst du noch keine Müdigkeit, keine Journalistenmüdigkeit?
Manchmal ist das tatsächlich so ein bisschen der Fall, aber der FC Bayern ist einfach viel zu lebendig und dynamisch, als dass man da irgendwie müde werden kann, darüber zu berichten, weil es passiert einfach ständig was und die Erfahrung hat mich eins gelehrt, wenn es ruhig ist, dann passiert gleich was. Das kommt aus einer irgendwie unvorhergesehenen Ecke dann vielleicht, aber prinzipiell habe ich schon noch Bock drauf. Und wenn die Zugänge nicht noch weiter beschränkt werden, dann macht es auch noch Spaß. Also es ist jetzt gerade so die Grenze, aufgrund der Ausführungen, die ich vorhin getätigt habe, aber wenn die Zugänge halt dementsprechend bleiben oder sich nicht weiter verengen, dann macht es schon noch Spaß.
Das ist schön. Dann werden wir dich noch aus weiteren Trainingslagern vor Ort mit deinen Aufsagern sehen können. Das freut uns alle sehr.
Aber gerne.
Daniel, vielen Dank, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast, uns mal ein bisschen Einblicke hinter deine Arbeit zu geben. An alle Hörer da draußen folgt diesem Mann bei Twitter. Er liest seine Artikel bei eurosport.com. Da geht es unter anderem auch um Wadenmuskulatur. Schaut euch natürlich unbedingt eure Aufsage an, jetzt wo ihr wisst, dass er sogar die Kamera selbst hingestellt hat. Also meine Güte. Daniel, vielen Dank, dass du dir Zeit dafür genommen hast. Und damit endet das erste Tribünengespräch in der Geschichte des Rasenfunks. Wir zünden uns jetzt eine Feuerwerksrakete an, die wir von Silvester noch gespart haben. Danke euch fürs Zuhören. Folgt uns in den sozialen Netzwerken at Rasenfunk auf Twitter, Rasenfunk auf Facebook, Google+, wenn ihr so abenteuerlustig seid. Und schaltet gerne wieder einen bei der nächsten Folge. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.